2022 is around the corner
and i can tell you uh december 31st of
02 i went to sleep we were at um
in front of in and out burger i've told
this story before we were at in and out
burger off of uh uh laurel canyon
universal studios and with a friend of
mine tam we're sitting in the car we
can't afford to buy a in-n-out burger
individually we buy double-double we
split it with our hands no joke we split
aboard
he has water i have water we say give us
two cups of water
with a ton of lemon and sweeten low we
took water we could make some lemonade
we made lemonade for free he drank it i
drank it we listened to ryan's secrets
to the countdown ten nine eight seven
six five four three two one wow and
there's this much excitement for me to
go from o2 to o3 we go to universal city
walk we cut we walk a little bit we
didn't even have the energy to go to
saddle ranch got back in the car went
back home i slept at like 12 31 o'clock
i said i will never go into a new year
not excited about the next year i'm
gonna change my life
12 months after that i become a broker
12 months after that i take my dad to
hawaii for the first time which was one
of his dreams because
he would always talk about he would say
yeah i said dad what does heaven look
like he says heaven's uh the closest
thing to heaven is a there's an island
next to california called hawaii one day
i will take you i took him to hawaii
february of 2004
and he walked around i looked at his
face i said dude this guy is so relaxed
december 15
of 2003 is the last time my dad had a
heart attack
december 15th december of 2003 is the
last time my dad had a heart attack
may 29th of 2004 is the last time my mom
or dad reached in their pocket to pay
for anything when they're around me may
of 2004. if you're around me i want to
pay for it
i wanted to change that reputation
december 21st that year was paulette's
birthday the the year prior to that
first birthday my sister i got her 20
gift card because i was so freaking
broke a year later when they went to
when they got married they didn't go on
an official honeymoon i went to their uh
christmas and i had my dad there see i'm
actor and paulette and i gave him an
envelope paula said here see him
it was a five night cruise to masatlan
that's never gonna give your this is
what i get sister and your
brother-in-law i saw the tears on their
eyes i saw the tear on cmax eyes my
dad's eyes my sister's eyes i said this
is what i freaking want to do the rest
of my life
i want to do this for the rest i want to
see the people around me dreams to
become i got addicted to that
that became a passion it was an
incredible feeling of what can happen if
you decide to change i want it to change
it is what's today's date december what
twenty-eight yeah okay we got four more
days if you count today got four more
days to finish after you're strong we
got a strong week this week we got who's
going to be on the podcast on friday by
the way uh brendan brando's shop is
going to be on the podcast on friday
that's right big time uh ufc comedian
you know he fought fade orb i can't wait
to talk to guys that's an absolute start
of a guy he was an ultimate fighter guy
yeah so brandon gerard is going to be
back he's going to be back tomorrow on
thursday on uh on thursday to be honest
he's flying back tomorrow which is great
but we're finishing off the year strong
and we're moving into a new building
there's about two buildings one there's
gonna be potentially the studio the
other one's gonna be the head and the
news it's in the real deals in the
realdeal.com the the
website but the moral the story is if
you're listening to this if you're one
of the few thousand people that are on
the podcast right now with us listen my
challenge to you if 2021 was a shitty
year
fox came out with a poll and they said
what
fox business poll seven in 10 say 2021
was a bad year for the country there's a
70 chance
2021 wasn't a good year for you there's
a 70 percent chance
2021 wasn't a good good year for you all
i'll tell you is the following
rather than looking on the outside blame
fauci blame biden blame trump blame your
boss blame your parents blame whoever
tyler can you turn off the mic please
rather than you blaming everybody about
that
make a list of what your reputation is
amongst your friends and family decide
to change recreate yourself and make
2020 2022 the beginning of the greatest
years of your life
anybody can do that you did that with
your life look where you are today
i did that with my life look where we
are today we started off with a small
podcast and it's grown we feel this is
going to be a top podcast worldwide
within the next two three four five
years if we continue with the schedule
that we have we have a message we want
the world to hear about
everything starts small but you got to
make a decision to change and change
your reputation someone needs to change
their reputation right so there's you
know however many people listen right
now and then uh you know the i'm sure
those make it a short clip if someone
needs to change their reputation is
there like a checklist all right step
one look in the mirror step two write it
down like is there something that you
think that people should actively do
because some people are just going to
listen to this and say all right yeah
you'd say
some people are actually going to try to
do it what should they do we were on a
zoom yesterday i was doing business
planning on monday for a few hours with
our guys and i asked one of the guys a
question i said
what percentage
of success
in the business of how you're dealing
with your guys
is based on how people
react
because it's the game and what
percentages on how you lead them
i don't know if you got that question so
what percentage of how your kids turn
out you think is on you the parent what
percentage is on them what percentage of
how good your sales people around you do
is on them versus on you i would say 80
20 80 is on who on the individual okay i
i say it's the other way around really
let me explain to you what i mean by
this
how can the same person work for five
different sales people
and
not make money with johnny not make
money with bobby not make money with
larry but they come to you they make a
quarter million dollars the same human
being it's a system
it's what you teach them it's how you
lead them right look at zapala right
sapala their best year was 160. right
now if they make 160 a month they're
disappointed if they make 16 under this
but they're gonna make three million
dollars this year okay if they make 160
a month they're disappointed they're
sitting on saying oh my gosh you know
whatever other stuff we should be making
200 000 a month i was with them just
a few days with their kids jojo and the
giant two-year-old kid jordan that looks
like six years old which makes no sense
that kid eats growth hormone he's i
don't know what that kid is on but that
kid is massive
um
book this name folks jordan zappala will
play in the nfl one day that's a special
kid he is a flippin beast strong jeans
boat sheena and matt anyways
um
you know you you got to make it to in a
way where you're honest with yourself
most of us don't want to say it's on
on ourselves most of us want to say it's
on somebody else the sooner you can
really be honest with your reputation
then you can change it so you're saying
it's not even on you it's on the person
leading you
no no i it is on you
absolutely it is on you what i'm saying
is i put it on me as the leader
okay but if i'm working for you i don't
put it on you i put it on me everything
to me is on me
whether i'm the sales leader whether i'm
the individual it's on me okay i can do
something about my life i'm gonna put it
all on me but we like to say it's not on
me it's on this person it's on that
person's on this person so
even as a sales leader you can say well
not how many sales people suck you know
the people here don't sell now it's
really on you okay because you can be a
better teacher you can be a better
leader you can be better at
communicating with your guys etc etc
uh anyways so
excited about 2022 to say the least we
got very very big plans so if you
enjoyed this little short segment from
the podcast that we did here's another
short segment to watch or if you want to
see the entire podcast click over here
take care everybody bye
[Music]